hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about scaffold proteins so scaffold
proteins sometimes called scaffolding
proteins are essential regulators of a
lot of important signaling pathways and
you can think of scaffold proteins as
being like the glue that holds some of
these signaling pathway components
together to increase their efficiency
and effectiveness excuse me
so scaffold proteins work through four
major functions one of the things they
do is they actually tether signaling
components together in order to increase
their efficiency what do we mean by
tether we have an example here scaffold
protein and purple plasma membrane and
blue and we've got a few different types
of proteins here
so some signaling components like kinase
is and black B proteins that they are
phosphorylated or their targets and
Krane and what you can see that the
scaffold protein does is it actually can
tether certain things together to
increase their efficiency
so without the scaffold protein holding
these kindnesses and close sort of
proximity to their target proteins the
kinases they might have to move through
the entire cell will be looking looking
for their target protein the scaffold
protein holds them together so that as
soon as the kinases are activated they
can go ahead and activate the downstream
target protein that's an example of that
tethering function the next function
where scaffolding proteins are so
important is they actually will localize
the signaling components to specific
regions so in the drawing here this
scaffold protein is holding these
proteins quite close to the plasma
membrane other scaffold proteins might
localize signaling
opponents close to the nucleus or close
to a mitochondrion wherever whatever a
region of the cell they're supposed to
be acted in the scaffold proteins can
make sure that they stay there another
important function of these scaffold
proteins is to coordinate positive or
negative feedback functions what this
means is that there are various types of
feedback in the cell positive feedback
is types of feedback that amplify a an
effect negative feedback is something
that slows the process down
and so scaffold proteins can help to
regulate some of these things so for
example scaffold proteins can make sure
that signaling components like the
kindnesses are only able to activate one
downstream target rather than amplify
but rather than active fiying multiple
downstream targets and having this large
amplification scaffold proteins can kind
of keep it from getting out of control
scaffold proteins can also actually in
some cases deactivate some signaling
components once they've had a chance to
work once or twice so perhaps a kinase
phosphorylates only one or two things
and then gets inactivated by the
scaffold protein and so that would be
like a form of of negative feedback the
fourth and final function we're going to
talk about today involves the scaffold
protein actually insulating or
protecting the signaling components from
inactivation or degradation so as an
example kinase is are important
signaling proteins they they activate
downstream targets by transferring a
phosphate group to them phosphatases are
enzymes that D phosphorylate things and
that can in innocence inactivate things
and some phosphatases can actually in
activate these kinase
well scaffold proteins can protect these
kindnesses from being inactivated by
ostentatious basically just by keeping
them apart
so by insulating these components at
keeping the kinases safe from the
phosphatases the kinase has have a
chance to do their job
the phosphatases cannot inactivate them
and studies show that kinase is that are
interacting the scaffold protein are
much less likely to be be phosphorylated
by phosphatases
in in general and so these scaffold
proteins can help to protect these
signaling components and help ensure
that they can do their job and not be
inactivated so that is the sort of
important function these four main
functions of scaffold proteins and you
can see how they really are an important
regulator of various signaling pathways
if you are interested in looking at any
of my other videos you'll find videos on
positive and negative feedback also on
enzyme activity and those are ones that
you might want to check out so thanks
for watching biology professor